je connais un moment mais non ils sont
nés en algérie donc ils ont ils ont un
peu traîné en allumant entrée comptait
beaucoup sur moi et ils font c'est
vraiment pourquoi assidus à l'école ils
sont en mode basé quoi c'est c'est votre
pépite
on veut qu'il devienne médecin ou ou
quelque chose comme ça je sais pas tu
vois mais malheureusement moi j'avais
trop ma tête qu'ils étaient prises par
salage évidemment
on va toute première console et le jour
de ma circoncision chez les musulmans
c'est assez répondu j'ai passé tout le
monde et social ces le produit contre
face à un cadeau et et j'ai eu la game
boy color je prends game boy color
[Musique]
alors qu'on paie ses polos starcraft je
l'avais allons criante et enfin les 600
bad
du coup je faisais plein de petits
boulots des formatages de pc j'écrivais
des lettres pour les gens du quartier
qui savaient pas à faire une lettre de
motivation leur cv et du coup ben vas-y
des mois et des mois
je récolte et 600 balles j'installe
starcraft et là c'est s'est terminée fin
c'est fini c'était un de l'école ça sort
de ma tête je suis à fond dans le jeu
le pire c'est que starcraft comme tu
joues faut être de l'intérieur regardez
les vidéos de joueurs pros ça bouge tout
le temps ça bouge tout le temps en fait
ça t'apprend le multitask ça c'était
celle des bases de cercle
c'est de faire plein de choses en même
temps toi
[Musique]
je suis arrivé j'étais stressé le patron
tu avais pas plus relevé qu'en
maintenant y avait une scène y avait
tout le monde s'est exprimé
et j'ai tremblé qu'à moi j'étais
stressée mais il fallait je libère la
pgw 2014 elle a tout changé au palmarès
top 4 pgw je pense je n'oublierai jamais
cette lan
je suis persuadé que je vais percer
c'est mon truc je le sais et je pouvais
pas le dire un monde arabe qui est
périodiquement ces manques tu vas pas
nous qui bloque les maillets tout pour
pas que j'y aille j'ai peur de le dire à
ma darron mais je suis parti voir ma
mère je lui dis ben je vais aller en
angleterre les chevelures s'était
soudain au début j'avais du mal à à
comment dire à à être moi-même pendant
mesrimes extérieur parce que il y avait
un peu de stress et j'étais pas tuer à
le faire donc tu vois j'ai c'est de
trouver le camel streamer alors qu'il
fallait pas du tout fallait juste être
kamel tout con mais vous arrête la
communauté elle est passionnée elle est
pas l ai pas fausse c'est à dire qu'ils
vont dire ce qu'ils pensent ce n'est pas
hypocrite même contre moi etc
s'il ya des moments où c'est terminé
avec sa rivale il veut pas hésité à me
dire et c'est pour ça que je les aime ça
peu importe ce qui va se passer
j'ai l'impression on a un peu on est
tout le temps ensemble
emmanuel macron à le l'accord bino 19
désolé désolé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec celui-là ça fait trois pas de
création juste ma lancée on va discuter
après ça à partir en feu et des bennes
c'est mary j plus d'émotions en général
jean vraiment j'ai l'impression
d'entendre servir à quelque chose de
bien
puisqu'on ne se rend pas compte que je
sais il ya des gens ils vont dire tu
stream et tu es kido soirée - des fois
je me sens pas bien je prends surtout ce
crime je kiffe etc
il le dit je l'entends mais tu es je
suis là je suis dans ma chambre il ya
juste mais écran devant moi et je
n'arrive pas à le capter directement ça
leur plaisait des buts on est la vente
une bonne cause vient de lever 1 5
million 700 mille euros j'ai pas les
chiffres exacts
j'ai plus droit allez vous verront plus
d'argent là c'est le retour du jamais vu
[Musique]
septième temps
le gâteau
à 0 déjà c'est du 6 6 jours sur 7 ça
c'est obligatoire
je m'impose un jour de repos même si on
exprime parce que je pense que j'ai
trouvé le meilleur taux possible avec un
avis et mes horaires donc genre six
jours sur sept
j'inscris une six à huit à dix heures
par jour et a pris à côté je dois signer
des trucs faire des appels etc
ça compte comme je travaille mais vas-y
ça arrive sur le table en prêt je ne
saurais pas de dire quoi je serais pas
dire tu serais vraiment beaucoup je
trouve et mais c'est parce que je kiffe
je suis passionné